and now please welcome a shining example  of the new America on the horizon who'd  like to say a few words of gratitude to  our honorable and faithful leaders I  want to say thank you thank you for your  kindness generosity of spirit and your  concern for our future at first we  rejected you but that was because we did  not understand we didn't realize how  much we needed you  we didn't appreciate that your arrival  was a precious gift  the president says rouse us from our  couple complacency  we have awoken from our wasteful sleep  and taking responsibility for our future  we have renewed pride in our work we are  once again  enterprising  resourceful  and cooperative  thanks to you we have rediscovered who  we are there's no turning back to our  apathetic and misguided ways a new day  has dawned and a brighter future beckons  and for this  say  thank you  you